In the next three quizzes, I'm going
to be challenging you to take advantage
of array methods, to programatically
create long chains of promises.
Keep in mind that you want
the thumbnails to appear on the page
in the same order as they appear
in the search results, but, and
this is an important but,
this does not mean that you need
to perform the request in series.
There are different strategies for
controlling the order that
promises resolve,
which you'll be trying out soon.
The keystone to all of these
strategies is the idea of a sequence.
You'll need to create a sequence
of promises that are chained,
one after another.